will you be giving bonuses to Executives
my my response to that question is to
say that we have a process a rigorous
process it is not my decision to Award
performance pay it is in fact the
decision of the board of directors and
that decision comes at the end of the
fiscal year we have another two months
before we reach the end of the fiscal
year and as I have also said in public
everything is on the table so we will
see at the end of fiscal year based on
results and where we are financially so
as a CEO you do not make the decision
you have no say in whether or not
bonuses are
granted all of the management team uh uh
measures and analyzes our
results on an annual basis which are
published very clearly in our in the
quter no say in whether or not bonuses
are given all of the management team
presents to the board of directors the
results of our year against kpis key
performance indicators that have been
tracked throughout the year and based on
the analysis and the results uh the
board of directors makes its decision I
should just point out perhaps of
interest for example last year we did
not meet two of our kpis and our bonus
level question now uh I I realize that
you'll do your best to talk about the
clock so I'll just kind of keep this
going along here